He may be the first Avenger, but he isn't
the chosen one.
And now we might know why, as a hilarious
new fan theory may explain just why Captain
America was unable to lift Thor's mystical
hammer Mjolnir in Avengers: Age of Ultron.
As most Marvel fans know, the hammer had an
enchantment on it that only allowed it to
be lifted by those deemed worthy.
"Whosoever be he worthy shall haveth the power!
Whatever, man, it's a trick!"
"Oh, please be my guest!"
In the comics, of course, Captain America
has lifted Thor's hammer several times, first
and most famously in the pages of Thor #390.
In the movies, however, the only people who
have been able to lift Mjolnir are the Vision
and, of course, Thor himself - though Steve
Rogers was able to at least budge the hammer,
something even War Machine and Iron Man were
unable to do despite their incredible strength.
"I think it moved."
(laughs)
"It moved?"
"It may have moved, I don't know."
So why is the movie version of Steve Rogers
unable to lift the hammer?
Reddit user ParameciaAntic has an insane - and
pretty funny - theory that suggests that Steve's
decision to ride a motorcycle without a helmet
at the end of Avengers is proof of his total
disdain for laws and authority - which other
Redditors quickly seized upon as the reason
he's unworthy to heft Mjolnir.
"You got a helmet?"
"Oh, oh I've got a helmet."
Of course, we have our own theory.
Sure, Captain America is worthy of lifting
the hammer, but you know who isn't?
The Human Torch.
And those aren't the only comic book characters
Chris Evans has played - he's also appeared
in adaptations of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles,
Snowpiercer, Scott Pilgrim vs. the World,
and The Losers.
"It was a secret government experiment.
They did stuff to me.
Spooky stuff."
That's why the hammer only budged when he
tried to lift it - because only part of him
was worthy.
"You know what I hate about myself…
I know what people taste like."
"That's gross…"
Then again, everyone has their own theory
- even the people who make the movies.
Back in 2015 during San Diego Comic-Con, a
fan asked Age of Ultron writer-director Joss
Whedon why Steve Rogers isn't considered worthy,
and why he couldn't properly lift Mjonlir.
Whedon suggested that maybe he is worthy,
but just didn't want to lift it, saying
"Are we sure?
Did he fail?
Or did he stop?"
In 2016, sibling filmmakers Joe and Anthony
Russo mentioned to Huffington Post that Captain
America wielding Mjolnir "[...] might be a
question for future storytellers" and that
it "[...] might be a little too specific for
us to answer."
Back then, the Russos were chatting about
their film Captain America: Civil War, but
in the years since, the pair went on to direct
Avengers: Infinity War, and they're also behind
the lens for Avengers 4.
So those "future storytellers" they referenced
back then may actually be the Russo brothers
themselves now.
Confusing, right?
But that little time paradox may actually
be in keeping with rumored plans to have Cap
actually lift Mjolnir in Avengers 4.
Sure, it's true that Thor's original hammer
was destroyed in Thor: Ragnarok by his evil
sister Hela, requiring him to make an all-new
weapon, the god-killer Stormbreaker, in Avengers:
Infinity War.
But according to a since-deleted Reddit post
purporting to have secret information about
the plot of Avengers 4, the team will travel
back in time to fight Thanos - and after a
Mjolnir-wielding Thor is struck down in battle
by Thanos, Captain America will lift the hammer
and gain the power of the Thunder God for
a final showdown of epic proportions.
No one can say for certain whether that will
definitely happen, but we wouldn't be surprised
if Avengers 4 really will include some element
of time travel, bring Mjolnir back into Thor's
life, and give Captain America a shiny hammer
to go with his signature shield.
After that jaw-dropping twist at the end of
Infinity War, we're expecting the unexpected
when it comes to the next Avengers movie.
We just hope it's all worth the wait.